你知道嗎？昨天看到一個超酷的創業故事，讓我對「白手起家」這個詞有了新的理解。
怎麼說？是哪方面的創新案例？
兩個大學生，在學期間從宿舍裡就開始創業，結果把公司做到了五千萬美元的市值，還在熱門創業節目上拿到了「雙重投資協議」！
從宿舍起家，做到五千萬美元？這確實出乎意料。一般人會覺得大學生資源有限，很難有大成就。他們具體是做什麼的？
原文沒有提到他們公司的產品是什麼，但重點在於他們是『如何在課餘時間』，而且是在『宿舍』這種環境下，做到這樣的規模。
這點很有意思。很多創業者會等待一個完美的時機或充裕的資源，但他們卻在一個相對限制的環境中開展。
對啊，這就是讓我詫異的地方。一般公司可能要等資金到位、辦公室裝潢好、團隊組建完整才敢大張旗鼓。他們卻是利用手邊現有的東西，邊學邊做。
的確，從文中來看，他們能獲得『雙重投資協議』，表示產品或商業模式本身具備強大吸引力，才能說服經驗豐富的投資者。
而且還強調是『雙重』協議，這表示不只一位投資人看好他們。能讓投資人打破常規，搶著投資，這中間一定有什麼過人之處。
聽起來，他們的核心競爭力可能不在於資金或場地，而在於對市場的洞察力，以及將想法付諸實踐的執行力。
對，原文雖然沒說具體產品，但強調他們是『從宿舍白手起家』，這說明了他們專注在獨特產品和市場策略，而不是被傳統資源框架綁住。
如果我是創業者，會從中學到的是，不要被『沒有資金』、『沒有人脈』這些藉口限制。真正的創業家會想辦法利用現有條件，創造價值。
而且他們在學期間就能做到，這其實也反映出他們對市場痛點的敏銳度。能讓課餘時間的興趣變成五千萬美元的事業，這真的很厲害。
是的。他們的成功軌跡也證明了『市場策略』的重要性。在有限的資源下，如何精準打入市場、獲得用戶，是他們能從小做大的關鍵。
那對我們一般上班族來說，這個概念能怎麼應用在工作上或生活裡呢？
我覺得，可以從『不被現有框架限制』這點來思考。工作中可能有很多我們覺得『沒資源、沒時間』的事。
嗯，就像常常覺得「這個專案如果資源再多一點，一定能做得更好」。
對。但如果我們能像這兩個大學生一樣，思考如何利用手邊現有的工具、團隊，在有限條件下，找到一個創新的解決方案，也許就能有出乎意料的成果。
聽起來，就是不要等萬事俱備，而是先從現有條件出發，找出那個『獨特』的價值點。
沒錯。可能只是在報告呈現方式上做點創新，或是主動優化一個流程，這些小小的嘗試累積起來，都能讓你在工作中脫穎而出。
也就是說，即使是日常工作，也能用創業家的思維去面對，去發掘那些被忽略的潛力。
完全正確。這種從零開始，用最少資源創造最大價值的精神，其實適用於任何層面。
真是個有啟發性的故事。下次遇到困難，或許可以想想這兩個大學生，他們是怎麼在宿舍裡變出一個五千萬美元的公司。
是的，他們的案例很鮮明地展現了，專注於『獨特產品』與『市場策略』，即使資源有限，也能創造巨大的商業成功。